being at the amusement park watching
your grandfather work can you talk about
how that shaped your business background
and then share some of the early lessons
you learned if you think of it this way
an amusement park you have an amusement
right
you have either it's a ride or it's
entertainment and around that you have
some sort of you have three different
profit centers generally you have
merchandise games of chance food and so
early on I learned this concept of what
you know people call it transmedia I
call it a sitting experience I'll tell
you why in a second but like I learned
like this has always been in my DNA like
how to create like basically how to
build out story worlds and so if you go
to an amusement park and they do it well
they'll create different sorts of
experiences throughout the park you know
like friends to go to Disney World you
have like you know Frontierland you'll
have like different sorts of things in
it but if you're in Frontierland you're
gonna eat barbecue every dress in
western gear and it looks that way so I
started to develop my film properties
pretty much the same way that I was
going to build out a story world just
not a linear storyline where people
could be entertained with different
facets of the of the of the content so
people can jump in and jump out of the
story line and everything else but it
was interesting though is as a kid I
started to realize certain business
things where I was outside of an office
one day and I heard my two uncles
debating about who's gonna get the syrup
contract between Coke and Pepsi and so
I'm like oh that's interesting because
they're exactly the same price right it
all came down how much free stuff that
we're gonna get and so and that's
literally what the deciding factor was
is how much free merch they were gonna
get him like huh
that's interesting and so from day one
of my filmmaking career I've always had
product placement all my films and it's
been something that it's one is I feel
like it makes this story that much more
authentic because you're using real
product but then number two is you get a
bunch of free stuff you know and then
with billboard we ended up even then
even giving us money for things too so
living in animal living you know as a
family having museum Park you gave me
completely different sensibility than a
lot of my peers have what did watching
your grandfather's business teach you
about sponsorship
um okay it's interesting as my
grandfather helped build it but that it
was his brothers and sisters that ran it
so his interesting cuz my grandfather
was pushed out of his will because my
grandfather wanted to race his kids
instead of being raised in the park so
he was completely ostracized from the
park early on so we had to work it and
everything because it was the family
tradition but my grandfather never got
into the riches from but whatsoever he
got when his when his father passed away
he got five hundred bucks and you know
that's the way it is it's what it was so
I just wanted to make sure that you
realize it was my grandfather was
actually my uncles and aunts we're
running it but it taught me a lot it
taught me a matter of one is taking care
of people's is very important realizing
that you know it is a business even
though we're in shell it makes you
realize that you know all the hard work
that goes into it you know the park
opens at you know twelve o'clock we're
there at 8:00 the park closes is that
you know at ten o'clock we're there
chill too you know so it's just a matter
of like so long we're par for the course
but it's also interesting to is like how
much ingenuity took place and also it's
a matter of like my great-grandfather
end up having a bunch of patents on on
on different sorts of concession things
and which is kind of interesting and but
also true was like had a change with the
times and it's interesting because in
the film industry people are so afraid
to change where and I'm a very early
adopter of a lot of stuff that's why
I've always been and in the
entertainment or in the amusement
business you have to be the same way you
have to constantly be fresh you have to
be new you can't be boring or else
people are gonna come year after year
you can't have the same old rides you
have to do something different you know
new spectacles when you saw that he put
in all this hard work and then in the
end maybe it didn't turn out exactly the
way he had planned or maybe it wasn't
that important to him did it teach you a
lot about putting sort of all your
energy and hope into something and maybe
it'll work out and maybe it wouldn't and
being still able to take that risk kind
of being free of like whatever the
outcome is um we were are born
takers or also we work very hard and we
will persevere like it's almost like
there's a line of stubbornness but you
keep working and reworking and do
whatever you can to make it work and you
know sometimes you have to pivot in a
different direction to make it work
but it's just a matter of if you are
honest you work hard and you have a
vision you basically do whatever you can
to make that that vision happen like my
grandfather because it was ostracized
from his own family sort of the keel and
at an airport you know the Allentown
Airport and it was interesting because
people still talk about it and my
grandfather literally built all the
rides himself he built all the
concession stands himself and it was
open from May until September and my mom
and Oliver sisters had to work it in
things so it's kind of interesting like
it's in our blood it's in our DNA to
kind of like do this sort of thing and
to persevere and to do we had to do to
make it but as a matter of like you know
like he was you know kind of like shrunk
from his own family what's pretty sad so
I think we already talked about this but
I'll just how many revenue streams does
an amusement park have gosh well you
have first of all you have admission
right and then you generally will have
your amusement whether it be a ride or
an entertainment let's say it's like it
like a song my dance routine or
something like that but then you have
merchandise you have your games of
chance and you have food an interesting
thing is is is Tony Park was founded as
it was a catering company first my
family moved over here from France and
the 1800's there all butchers and to
sell more food they brought in a
carousel and that's how the whole Park
started was literally started out as a
food operation and to sell more food
they built amusements and my
great-grandfather came very friendly
with Walt Disney because they're opposed
to a right next door to each other at
Fort Lauderdale in Florida and and when
when Disney was building you know Disney
World in Orlando it was it was
interesting because you know Disney had
a completely different view on what he
was doing versus what grandfather's
doing
Disney was a dreamer my grandfather was
a money maker and and his his sole
purpose was really to entertain but as
you entertain people people forget about
what they're spending and they spend
more money oh that's a great point you
know and it's kind of it's it's it's
like one of those things and so I'm not
saying that every amusement park is
built the way that my grandfather my
great grandfather built his but that's
that that was like literally DNA of it
so it wasn't originally supposed to be
in a music park it was to sell more food
so the food was unbelievable and so then
you also understand why he has all these
patents on concessions like you know
would like ketchup and mustard
dispensers that would like basically
turn and and the condiment flow out he
actually patented the waffle iron that
flips all these weird things just to be
able to sell more more food so when it
comes to filmmaking which would you say
you are the Walt Disney model or your
grandfather's Wow
I'd say both because it's funny because
I write direct and produce I will
produce other people's work but I'll
will direct what I write and then uh
producing it as well but I am a dreamer
as a Disney and I do create everything
from scratch but its same time and very
practical like for instance with
billboard we ended up driving revenue
very early on to the project we were
cashflow positive before we ever shot
any film because we ended up selling
billboard spaces throughout the content
and so I mean module would cost a lot
more than just the billboard spaces you
know like we you have I have a bunch of
money wrapped up in it but so I'm a
pragmatist and also a dreamer at the
same time I think that's what's made me
somewhat successful is because I can
think both ways and at the same time if
I know that I have to make that dream
happen I'll work my butt off to make it
happen that makes sense
so
you